branches are one of git's most important
concepts
in this course tobias will give you a
thorough understanding on how branches
work and get
and don't forget to hit that subscribe
button so you don't miss any of our
great courses
hello free code camp friends my name is
tobias and i'm going to
explain how to work with branches in git
one of the core and most important
topics in git and version control
is how you can productively work with
your branches and what
you can do to start off but before we go
let me have a huge shout out to the
people at free code camp
for teaching people how to code for free
on the internet thank you so much
for being on that mission and thank you
for letting me help a little bit with
that
contribution a couple of words about
my background i'm part of the team
behind tower
tower is a graphical user interface for
git
on mac and windows and we've been around
for more than
10 years now and in those 10 years we've
helped around 100 000 people
in companies big and small freelancers
every developer in in every part of the
the world
work more easily with the git version
control system
take the headache out of git and make it
more more easy
this workshop today will not be about
tower don't worry you don't have to
have tower installed we will do
everything on the command line so you
can follow along
no matter what you're using
so before we start what's this gonna be
about
branches are one of the core concepts in
git and there's really an endless amount
of things
you can do with them you can create and
delete them you can compare
you can merge and rebase them you can
publish and track them
so we're talking about all of those
things that you can do with your
branches
before we dive into the specifics
let me just briefly talk about two core
concepts that i'll mention again and
again
so one is the head branch if you don't
know that term that's
pretty important it is the currently
active or the checked out branch you can
have many branches in your repository
but you can have only one and that is
active at a single time so if you hit
get status on your command line or are
in a graphical user interface you will
see you are
on a certain branch in this example here
on
branch master so master is currently the
head branch the active branch
and the other core concept is the
distinction between local and remote
branches
so when we're working with
branches we are in 99 of the time or 95
of the time we're working with branches
in our local git repository right
the remote branches in your github
gitlab
bitbucket azure devops whatever you have
that they're more for synchronizing
right the the bulk of the actual work
happens in your local branches on your
local
machine in your local git repository
all right let's start
by creating new branches
right so before you can work with
branches you of course need to have
some in in your repository and
to create a new branch you can just use
the git branch
command and provide the name of your
branch so
my new branch is the name of that new
branch
and when i do it like that when
providing just a name to the git branch
command
git will assume that i want to start my
new branch based on the currently
checked out revision
so i'm going to create a new branch on
the situation
that i was to this point
so if i'd like to create a new branch at
a specific
other revision let's say let's see what
revisions we have in this repository
by the way so this is this is tower the
graphical user interface that we make
so here is my new branch i just created
that so that worked
good news if i want to create my branch
on a different revision let's say i want
to start
well here i can just copy the
revision hash of that commit here
and then on the command line i can type
git branch
other branch that's the name and i
wanted to start
on that revision here all right let's
see what that did
all right a new branch so that worked
and it started
on that revision here right so you're
pretty flexible
with how you want to start your branches
and again as i mentioned briefly in that
core concept area just a few seconds ago
you can only create new branches in your
local repository right
creating branches in a remote repository
happens by
publishing an existing local branch so i
can
i can upload these here but i can't
create a branch on a remote we'll talk
about that later on
all right git branch
either without mentioning a specific
revision then it's
going to be your current revision
or mentioning a specific one to start it
on a specific revision
all right switching branches of course
another
very important action you're going to
use
all of the time so the the current
branch the checked out branch so to say
oh the head branch
it defines the context your work is in
at the moment
and the current head branch is where new
commits will be
created they will be created in that
context
um and to change uh the branch you're
currently working in
um this means to check out another
branch or to switch
a branch and let's see how we can do
that
all right so at the moment if i hit get
status
i can see i am on branch main so main is
currently checked out this is my head
branch
and if i want this to be a different
branch i can type git
check out and well we have so many
beautiful new branches
get new branch and voila i've switched
to branch my new branch so the git
checkout
command is pretty versatile it's it's
used for so many things
um in recent years there's been a new
command
added to the the git command palette
and i would suggest you use git switch
in the future because git switch is only
for this purpose
it's only for switching branches so if
we want to switch
to well we created other branch i can
type git switch other branch and
git switch as i said is a little bit
more unambiguous
because it only has this purpose git
checkout is a command with
lots and lots of meanings so i'm more
comfortable
using get switch
get checkout and git switch again
so you can see in a graphical user
interface this is where the head
pointer now points to so other branches
currently that checked out the active
branch
okay number three renaming branches it's
pretty easy to mistype a branch's name
or to
change your mind after the fact so don't
worry you can
rename branches of course and git makes
it pretty easy to rename your local
head branch so let's do that so
we are currently on again let's
type git status to make sure we are on
branch other branch
and if i'm not happy with that naming i
can just
change it using git branch with the dash
m parameter and then provide a new name
so
a better branch let's call it like that
and take another look okay i'm now on
branch better branch that was pretty
easy
so in case you want to
rename a different branch not the head
branch not the currently checked out
branch
then we have to provide the name of the
old branch to to make this
unambiguous so at the moment we have
let's see what branches we have
we're using git branch without any
parameters all right so better branch
main and my new branch so let's say i
went
to rename a none head branch a branch
that is not currently checked out
let's say i want to rename my new branch
here so
let's make some room
all right so let's rename and get
branch dash m my new branch
and call it my better branch
let's see if that work get branch
without any parameters shows you what
branches you currently have and voila we
just changed the name of a non-head
branch um like this
so these commands are used to work for
changing local branch names if you'd
like to rename a remote branch
things are a little bit more complicated
because git doesn't allow you to rename
remote branches really so in practice
renaming a remote branch
can be done by deleting the old one and
then
pushing up publishing the new one from
your local repository so
let's take another look at what we have
so if i'm not happy with
origin staging that naming here i can
delete that and then re-upload it
and i'll show you how to publish upload
your
branch for the first time in a second so
we can see how that works
all right renaming branches with the get
branch
dash m command and if you have a
non-head branch that you want to rename
provide the old name and then the new
name
this is for renaming remote branches and
we'll do that
while we are creating a new branch and
pushing that for the first time so we
can do two things in one
all right publishing branches as i
already said it's
not really possible to create a new
branch on a remote repository
what we can do however is we publish
an existing local branch on a remote
repository
so we can upload what we have locally
to the remote server and thereby share
it with our team
right so let's see what we have and what
we can
publish okay
so at the moment we have this beautiful
feature uploader branch
here and it's not present on the remote
so let's say i want to publish that for
the first time i want to upload it
to the remote server named origin let's
let's do that on the command line
so i can just use get push dash u
i'll explain what the new flag is in a
second
on the origin remote and it's the
feature
uploader branch
all right looking good
all right here we go so we've just
uploaded that
to that branch here that local branch to
the remote repository
now we'll be talking about this dash u
flag here in great detail in a second
but
to give you the the the nutshell uh
right now
it tells git to establish a tracking
connection
and this means pushing and pulling later
on will be
much much much much more easy in the
future
so let's talk about that in detail
because the whole topic of tracking
branches is really
important to understand by default
local and remote branches have nothing
to do with each other they are stored
and managed as
independent objects in git but in real
life of course
local and remote branches often do have
a relationship with each other
for example a remote branch is often
something like a
a counterpart of a local one right
such a relationship can be established
in git
so one branch typically a remote one or
a local one sorry
can track another one typically a remote
one
so in in this little diagram here you
can see we have a local branch that's
called develop
and we have a remote branch on the
origin remote
that's also called develop and of course
i want them to have a relationship with
each other they're
the counterparts of each other and
with that tracking relationship
established
when i later pull or push when i push
from my local branch or pull from my
remote branch
i can simply use the vanilla git
commands i can use git push and git pull
without
any further
flags or parameters because the tracking
connection already knows
and it can fill in the blanks so which
branch
on which remote do i want to push to or
pull from for example all of that is
already saved in the tracking connection
and we've already used such one way to
establish such a tracking connection
when we use git push with the u option
to publish that local branch
and after that as i said we can just
just use git push without mentioning the
remote or the target branch or the
source branch
this all works out then and this also
works the other way around so
what we did was publish a local branch
to a remote repository but we can also
go ahead and
track or download a remote branch and
bring it to the local repository right
the other way around is also possible
and we can also establish a tracking
connection like that
so let's see what we have
this would be number five
and um we currently have
[Music]
right a feature login branch on the
remote
that is not present here in my local
branches
so let's say somebody else worked on
that feature login branch and
i want to join that work and
work with that branch so let's get that
branch to my local branches
and the way to do that is either to use
get
branch with the dash dash track
option and this will be feature
login and it's coming from origin
feature login
so by that i created a local branch
called feature login
that is based on origin feature login
and they know about each other right i
established that
tracking connection and voila here we go
we now have that locally
and in a graphical user interface like
tower i can
see that yes there is a tracking
connection right this local branch
tracks the remote one
another way to do that well let's
create another branch
feature
downloader so we have another local
branch that is not present on the
um on the remote i will
publish that really quickly
and then remove it from
here from my local branches
right so again we have that situation i
want to have that feature downloader
branch
um on my local branches and currently
it's only present on the remote
so another way to do that instead of git
branch dash
track is to use the get
checkout command and again with the
track option so that's the same and i'm
basing that
on origin feature downloader
and by not naming a local branch and
just specifying
the the base remote branch
git uses that
branch name for the local branch's name
so i now have feature downloader here
again
same thing as before so it doesn't
really matter if you're using git branch
dash
track or get checkout dash track it's
just another way of doing that
okay tracking branches very important
either with git branch dash track or
with git checkout
dash dash track
pulling and pushing branches so once you
have your tracking connection set up
properly
pulling and pushing is really simple and
almost boring actually
so that's why i strongly suggest to work
with the commands i showed you before
either
when publishing a local branch with git
push dash u or when tracking a remote
branch from the other side
with a get checkout dash track command
because again once this tracking
connection is set up
all you need to do is use git pull and
get push to sync your branches right
get pulled to download new commits from
the remote probably
from your colleagues and get pushed for
uploading or publishing your own
new work to the remote server you don't
need
with these tracking connections setup
you don't need any additional parameters
you don't need to specify
the remote like origin and the base
branch or the target branch or the
source branch
just get pull and get push is enough um
so that's the real advantage of using
those
tracking connections um
let's take another look at what we have
here
and see what's happening okay so
currently we are
on the feature login branch and
the another um advantage of having those
tracking connections set up is
that git tells me if my local branch
and the tracked remote branch diverge
and that means
let's take another look at tower and
what what this looks like
so this feature login branch here has
little numbers here and this means one
commit
hasn't been pushed yet so the remote
version of that branch
doesn't have one commit that i produced
locally and the other way around
two commits are present on the remote
end
probably a co-worker or teammate made
some commits
and i haven't pulled those down i
haven't downloaded those
so this is really interesting to stay on
track and
and understand how local and remote
branches diverge
if there's something that i forgot to
push or haven't pushed yet
or if that's something that i need to
pull i need to update
[Music]
and with the on the command line with
the git branch
dash v command i can get the same
information so
i see feature login is ahead one
behind two ahead means i have a local
commit that is not pushed yet behind
means
i am behind the remote so there are new
commits on the remote that i haven't
pulled
pretty interesting information um to
understand
where you are how act how
current your data is you could say
all right the leading branches so
most branches are not meant to live
forever um
and i encourage you to do a little bit
of house cleaning
now and then and here's how to delete a
local branch that's
pretty easy so let's move to
number seven and see what we have
okay feature uploader and main are there
the first thing you know
to know is you cannot delete
the current head branch so if i were to
type git branch
d and feature uploader
i would get an error message because i
as i said i can't delete the
the branches currently active that is
currently head
so first i would have to step away from
that get switch
main make main or another branch active
and then
i could use git branch d
and feature uploader to do that
loader and deleted branch feature
uploader so this is now
gone right i deleted that
um in some cases you will again get an
error message
um because let's say you have worked on
a local feature branch for some time
produced some commits
and then understand okay this this
doesn't lead anywhere i
need to delete that you've produced new
commits that are present
nowhere else and if you try to delete
that branch
git will say well be careful you are
about to
delete data that is present nowhere else
these commits haven't been integrated
into other branches
so are you really sure and that's when
you need to use the dash
f option force to force the deletion
needless to say i guess that this is
quite a destructive
action with dash f for force so
be careful you have a hard time getting
those commits back
you can don't worry um but
it's it has its reasons why it warns you
well
these commits are present nowhere else
are you sure you want to delete that
branch
another thing you might want to do is
delete
a remote branch and as you already know
working
with branches on the local end is
different than working on the remote
so it's a different command
get branch let's see what we have first
so let's say we want to delete that
origin feature
downloader branch here on the remote
and we can do that using git
clear up a little bit get push
again and i want to remove something
from
origin and the delete flag
is used here for feature down
loader
and let's see all right
boom there it is gone so
maybe another important thing to
remember is when deleting a branch
doesn't matter if it's a remote one or a
local one
keep in mind to check if you should
delete its counterpart branch too right
the tracking branch so
for example if you've deleted a remote
feature branch it might
make sense to also delete its local
tracking branch
that way you make sure you aren't left
with lots of obsolete branches and
a messy git repository of course so
always keep in mind
when i delete one branch is there a
counterpart branch
on the other end either local or remote
and should i delete that too
maybe okay
deleting on the remote with git push and
dash delete merging branches
pretty interesting topic merging is
probably the most
common way to integrate changes so
essentially you're bringing new commits
from another branch
into your current head branch that's
always the direction right you're
you're integrating into your current
local head branch
from another branch and merging in in
most cases is
very easy in in git and very simple
different to other version control
systems so that's one reason why it's so
popular
and essentially it just requires two
steps so first
you need to make active the branch that
you want to
have the changes come into that that
should receive the changes
and then execute execute the merge
command with the name of the branch that
has the desired changes let's see
what we have here in our example
scenario
okay so at the moment main has
a new commit that is this one here title
of error page corrected
and uploader has also a different commit
clarify css background rule
so they diverge and let's say i want to
integrate um this commit here or
these changes the new commits on feature
uploader
into main right i want to bring the new
changes into
the main branch then i can just
switch to main make main active
and then just type git merge feature
what was it
uploader
and voila i'm getting an editor with it
why is that
because merging most often not always
produces a merge commit right think of
that like a
a not that combines or that connects two
branches
and this is a new commit so i can
provide a new commit message
and i'm going with what git provides
here as a standard
merge branch feature uploader just close
that
and let's see what happened on main
voila i just combined these two branches
and
and i have all of the changes here from
both branches
so this is what the end result looks
like as i said there is
this merge commit here that combines the
changes from
both branches and
there is another way of integrating
changes and that is
rebasing so this is just an alternative
way to integrate commits from
one branch into another and
it's very important to stress that this
is not better or worse this is not the
the pro version and the
merges the beginner version it's simply
different
if and when you're using rebase it
mainly comes down to your personal
preferences and the conventions in your
team
and the situation so some teams love
rebates some prefer merge
and some do in some cases and not in
other cases so
it's not a matter of better or worse
that's important to understand
so let's compare merge and rebase so you
understand what's
the difference so this is the the
starting situation we have two branches
we have branch a
and branch b and both have um diverting
changes or different changes so we have
a couple commits here and one commit
here
and they they were branched off on on
this point here
now with merge you've already seen that
we would receive this
merge commit in the end this melting
point or this knot that combines these
two commits
using rebase on the other hand the end
result will look quite different
so especially because there is no
separate merge commit that will be
created that's a big difference
using rebase it appears as if
development history had happened in a
straight line
there's not this this um branching out
anymore
it happens or it looks like it was a
straight line
and this has its pros and it's cons so
but that's the
the result and the big difference
and then starting the actual process is
pretty simple but let's
do that in practice um
this is case number nine
and let's see what we have right so a
pretty similar situation like before on
feature uploader i have
two commits these here that are present
nowhere else and on
main i have this here that is present
nowhere else
and let's say i would like to integrate
the changes from main
into my feature uploader branch right
so the first step would be to switch to
feature uploader to make that the head
branch because
as with merge i am always integrating
into
my head branch right the head branch is
the one that's being manipulated
um i am already on
feature uploader so nothing to to do
here
but the second step is git rebase and i
want to rebase
on main and that was already
it let's see what happened now you can
see this
title of error page corrected commit
that used to be on main
is now also present here on uploader and
as you can see there's not this
branching out this
this melting knot no merge commit this
looks like a straight line and that's
the big difference between
merge and rebase again if you're using a
graphical user interface like tower you
can just drag and drop to merge or if
you keep the alt key pressed it becomes
rebase
so these actions are pretty
straightforward in a graphical user
interface
all right and so this is rebasing again
and final case or final action
comparing branches sometimes it's pretty
helpful to compare
two branches so for example before you
decide to
integrate or delete a branch you want to
see how it differs from another branch
does it contain any new commits or not
do i still need those
what's the difference so let's
do this in practice
and see what we have
so similar situation to just before
feature uploader and main they diverge
they have different
commits and let's compare that and see
what is actually different between them
so
i can type get
log main double dot
feature uploader and
this shows me which commits are in our
feature
uploader branch but not in our main
branch
and thereby i can see okay these two
commits
are here but not here and this would
also of course mean
if i integrated into
main these two commits would make it
into the integration
so i can understand the difference
between those two
if i want to see what's the difference
between
a local and a remote branch i can also
do that
same thing actually so let's compare my
local main
with the origin main and the process is
pretty similar git log
main all right let's start with origin
main
and main and i can see okay i have
one commit currently in my local main
that is not
present in my remote branch origin main
so i know
okay if i pushed now i would upload
this commit here because it isn't
present there
all right um
i think this is it for today
to help you remember what you learned i
prepared a little cheat sheet about this
topic so
about all of the different commands that
you can use in in
regard to working with branches uh just
hop
on bitly get branches cheat sheet and
download that for free
this comes in handy in your daily work
i'm sure of it
and you can download the cheat sheet for
free as you like
i hope there's a little bit of new
information for you
here in this workshop and in the cheat
sheet have fun
creating deleting renaming tracking
pushing pulling comparing branches
and work with git thanks for your
attention take care